the FOMC's assessment that it can be
patient and beginning to normalize
policy means that the committee
considers it unlikely that economic
conditions will warrant an increase in
the target range for the federal funds
rate for at least the next couple of
FOMC meetings that a modification of the
forward guidance should not be read as
indicating that the committee will
necessarily increase the target range in
a couple of meetings if economic
conditions continue to improve as the
committee anticipates the committee will
at some point begin considering an
increase in the target range for the
federal funds rate on a meeting by
meeting basis there has been important
progress toward the FOMC's objective of
maximum employment however despite this
improvement too many Americans remain
unemployed or underemployed wage growth
is still sluggish and inflation remains
well below a longer-run objective before
raising rates we will want to feel
confident that the recovery will
continue and that inflation is moving up
over time audit the Fed is a bill that
would politicize monetary policy would
bring short-term political pressures to
bear on the Fed what I think is really
critically important is that the Fed be
able to deliberate on the best way to
meet the responsibilities that Congress
is assigned to us to achieve maximum
employment and price stability and that
we be able to do so free of short-term
political pressures